وترامب هيوحو بالعوده ساترشحوا على الارجح
بينما ايضا قلق للغايه على الديمقراطيه
ومن اجل ذلك الانتخابات النصفيه مهمه ومن
اجل ذلك تصرف على اعلاناتها المليارات نحو
تسعه مليارات و 700 مليون دولار الانفاق
الاجمالي المتوقع في الانتخابات النصفيه
للكونجرس بحسب شركه
للابحاث رقمهن قياسي يفوقوا السباق في
الانتخابات 2018 بمئه واربعه واربعين في
المئه وابقى الاقامه بس التكلفه الاجماليه
للانتخابات الولايات والانتخابات
الفدراليه يتوقع ان تصل الى 16 مليار و700
مليون دولار متغطيه حاجز ال 14 مليار
دولار التي انفقت في انتخابات الرئاسه
الامريكيه الاخيره
احتدامه الحرب الحزبيه والاستقدام
السياسيه الداله لرفع قيمه الرهانات
الانتخابيه لمجموعات المصالح والشركات
سعيا بضمان مصالحها استقطاب تعاكسه
الارقام 80% من الديمقراطيين والجمهوريين
يعتقدون ان الحزب المنافس يشكل تهديدا
سيدمر اميريكا اذا لم يتم ايقافه اليوم
ولهذا فهي الانتخابات الاهم في حياه
الامريكيين برامج مثل اكتبلول
الديمقراطيين ووين براد للجمهوريين سهله
المساهمات الصغيره هذا العام تبرع الاشخاص
بمبلغ 200 دولار او اقل ليصل الاجمالي الى
نحو مليار و100 مليون دولار
هيضعفها ما كان عليه الحال عام 2018
هذا العام ايضا كان ارتفاع تبرعات القادمه
من خارج الولايه ما يقرب من ثلثي التبرعات
اللي مرشحين مجلس الشيوخ جاء من مساهمين
مخارج الولايات بدلا من الناخبين
المحتملين لكن هل لهذه الاموال تاثيرا
فعليه على الفائز
الاحصاءات تجيب بنعم خلال ال 20 عاما
الماضي عادتا ما يفوز المرشح الذي ينفق
اكثر اتجاه اقوى في مجلس النواب منه
للشيوخ لكنه ايضا موجود في الاثنين سباق
مجلس شيوخ الاكثر اعتدادا وبالتالي الاكثر
جد للمبالغ القياسيه يتوقع ان تتجاوز
نفقات اربع معارك انتخابيه فيها اليسونه
جورجيا نيفادا وسلبيا حاجز المئتين مليون
دولار لكل منها المفارقه تكمن في ان
المعركه الاغلى في الانتخابات خاليه من اي
مرشح بل هي استفتاء على مشروع الصراع يشرع
المراهانات الرياضيه عبر الانترنت في
ولايه كاليفورنيا اكثر من 400 مليون دولار
من الدعايه لكل من عميل الفكره ومعارضينها